the jogan experience and then you got to
figure out how to sneak up on animals
and just launch these
[__] feather
covered darts of death and and it's one
of the most the greatest technological
advant advantages of hunting that humans
had ever created yeah they created the
ability to kill something that's really
far away good a good Archer can shoot
something with a traditional bow 40 50
60 yards away you're right and a chimp
can never figure that out but if they
did we'd be [__] we'd be [__] hard
we'd be [__] they would just storm
cities just shooting people for fun they
would 100% shoot you for fun I agree and
oh by the way they' eat your babies
there's been a lot of documented cases
of chimpanzees eating human babies
stealing human babies and eating them
really oh yeah baboons too baboons have
stolen babies and eaten them it's a real
problem you ever seen that video of this
like little kid is wearing a diaper and
uh they're out in the street and this
[__] Mony steal tries to steal the
baby tries to steal the baby yeah this
monkey pulls up in like a motor scooter
and that's right yeah and grabs the baby
drag it off they have to chase the
monkey to get the baby back I remember
that yo yo that's pretty sick that's
plan of the Apes right there imagine if
he had a gun we just bang bang
bang just it is if that monkey had a gun
100 in front of his
parents and draag tries to drag it off
and it's moving pretty fast too man with
something that's way bigger than him and
this guy's even he is and he's used to
it because look at this guy he's not
even running he's just like what what
country they in it kind of looks like
the monkey's actually being yanked back
on a oh you're right oh wait a minute
wait a minute play that again you're
right you're right oh my God it's a
stunt watch right here barely got
leverage to do that yeah how's he moving
so fast I know I that one arm starts
pointing at oh yeah you're right but
where so there would be someone behind
him with a cable attached to him yeah
wow that's crazy if that's true is there
a harness on that monkey do you see a
harness or anything not really boy it
does look like something around his neck
right there around neck you can Bo it
does seem like something his neck goes
this way did you see that somewhere do
you just see that right now I vaguely
remembered seeing something about it but
like I'm just seeing it right now I like
what that's looks look how's it moving
where's it getting the leverage to move
that way look how fast look it's getting
dragged cuz otherwise how would it have
the leverage to move that fast look at
the line you could you could sort of see
yes you could see it oh my God it is
it's a cable D I fell for that too maybe
that's how monkeys steal babies maybe
they use monkeys to steal kids oh that's
even scarier dude wow maybe they've
train monkeys to steal kids maybe that's
what it is and we just watched it wow no
the guys were well or they're showing
everyone how to do it this is how we do
it here listen that's totally going to
show you how you do you should do it
well can we agree that people steal kids
oh yeah 100% so if that's true there
people so you want some C I think it
almost happened to me if if people are
so evil that they would steal kids which
is real thank you then you don't think
they would train monkeys to help them
what are you crazy of course they would
that's terrifying not only your kid get
stolen kid gets stolen by a monkey and
the what's this one jerie I mean I was I
was looking for proof and I found a
different video of almost the same thing
happened a monkey stealing a baby on a
leash so these people ran away they ran
away from the kid
that's real right there why did they run
away they ran away from that baby that's
so
crazy is he trying to and then the mom
came by and the mom got the baby oh my
God he didn't want to let go of the baby
wait put back with these kids oh my God
that's
crazy that's crazy oh maybe yeah maybe
it was a bunch of
kids little kids but still that boy run
around run back fella save that [__]
baby [__] that was your sister your
little brother e e don't don't show me
that again all right so but isn't that
Society you what do you think how do you
think You' do if a monkey was trying to
steal a baby you think you'd [__] up a
monkey oh dude I I i' go for him I'd
start kicking hard I know he'd come
after me though but I wouldn't I'd be in
it too late he might tear my ass apart
but I'm now if it was a chimp I don't
know I you never CH i' do a lot of this
you'd have no chance to get and I'd lie
but I wonder how much chance you'd have
against a monkey I'd lie and say hey man
I tried to help it's just I couldn't get
in there like I was looking at that
monkey I was like what would my strategy
be we play it back can you play it back
yeah let me see that again I think I go
straight for try to kick him the monkey
that's on the stairs I think I'm punting
that monkey I think I'm gonna let that
monkey feel it yeah I see kick him
really hard in the head yeah I'm going
to
sh him good right in his head mhm I'm
going to or in his gut I'm going to
power Kick That Monkey into another
dimension but I'm going to be ready for
that thing to bite my dick like you
that's not a like a little thing that
that 35b animal or whatever the [__] it
is has insane power and it's Fearless
Fearless of these so you got to right
there you got to smash mon you got to
smash that monkey you got to really put
the boots to him and he also knows you
don't have the power to fight like well
what you got to do really is grab him
you grab him by his back legs if you can
or his tail you grab him first of all
you kick him as hard as you can but if
you do get in Scramble with him you try
to pile drive him into the ground that's
what you try to do you try to smash him
into the ground as hard as you can like
that might be your only way out it's
going to be hard to do cuz he's going to
recognize what you're doing he's
probably going to be able to twist and
turn and stop a lot of the force but if
you could figure out a way to slam that
monkey into the ground over and over
again repeatedly I think you'd break it
eventually but he'd be biting the [__]
out of a tough task i' go for ta would
be biting the [__] out of you he would
be jumping for your face but you got to
you got to beat the [__] out of that
monkey what about the
the tail thing is it's going to turn
around and bite you it's going to grab
you the way they can move they move so
much better than us so you you have to
accept that this little thing is
probably as strong as you I'm see I'm
cocky right now I'm confident I'm I'm
I'm going to twir I think those 35lb
monkeys are as strong as you and me I'll
double hand them how like a like a how
strong is what what is that a racist
monkey what kind of monkey is that uh I
don't know I think I'd get [__] up I
think I might be able to kill it but I
think I'm getting [__] up along the
way I'm getting clawed at it's clawing
at my eyes it's trying to bite my face I
don't think it would get to your face
though that monkey I don't think get to
Joe Ran's face I'm being honest with you
you could be shocked at how fast and how
strong a monkey is and if you don't
[__] move accordingly if you don't
stop it while it's happening if you
allow it to get a grip on you you might
be really [__] it might get your
jugular like there's a video of this guy
there's this old man and he's sitting
there on the ground and this monkey
climbs on him and he's like sort of
accepting that this monkey is on him and
this monkey decides to scalp him so this
monkey just clamps down on his head and
peels an enormous slice of skin off this
guy's head what size monkey is this a
small monkey a monkey like that monw
exactly like that monkey so what I'm
trying to say is I think you're in in
your head you're thinking see here this
guy look at this guy so this is the same
kind of monkey right okay this guyy
sitting there and watch this monkey oh
[__] oh dude oh it just bit him and took
a giant chunk of his head off so that's
what I'm saying this is what you're
dealing with oh damn yeah you you are
not dealing with wait a minute yeah
that's his that's his head bro just bit
into his head and took an enormous chunk
of his scalp
off yeah and you just saw
it this is the thing I I think you need
to reassess wait wait let me where you
are with this monkey watch this it just
bites him and dude it could do that to
your face it would grab your nose and
you wouldn't be able to get it off your
nose rip your [__] nose why is his
head bleeding his head's not bleeding
cuz that's what happens dude it bleeds
out of the part where there's skin left
Jim Brewer there's no skin you're
looking at skull you're looking at skull
so all Jim all the things that bleed are
now gone that's the stuff that bleeds
skin so all the skin that is bleeding is
the skin that's around it and it's
bleeding into the [__] cracks where
his scalp's been removed to his head
that's real as [__] all right maybe
that's a I'm thinking that monkey might
[__] you up I think you have to really
reassess what you think a monkey is you
can't treat a monkey like it's a little
person that's a way more ferocious
powerful thing it's you're looking at it
proportionately because we think we're
pretty big in compared to that monkey so
we're stronger but we're not we're just
bigger all right so when I when I go for
this fight for $40 million you're going
to be my trainer I'm not training you
get killed you're going to get killed
you you need years and you need to get
on steroids immediately what is the um
monkey type that bite that guy's head
off cuz I think that's the same kind of
monkey this corner we got to get you on
the full usada protocol whatever usada
says you can't take we're going to put
you on it I'm going to have a cape with
a big VOR Belfor in his prime just all
trapped [__]
Jack and here comes the monkey you still
might get killed by that monkey we might
have to train you for does the monkey
come in a leash no no the monkey free
the monkey's running you're in a cirular
yeah I would have to train you for a
decade a full decade we have to just to
give you a chance just a chance to live
really uh-huh yeah I think so all right
I think you're dealing with a totally
different thing I think you think of it
like it's like a little person but it's
not it's not it's way stronger it's it's
way stronger than a person I would way
rather fight 150 lb man than a 35 lb
monkey if I found a man you're talking
about AED man 50 lbs less man than me I
like my odds way more than I like my
odds against a [__] monkey look at
that thing those are serious fangs dude
it's too strong you don't understand how
strong it is you think it's little so it
can't be as strong as you but it's as
strong as you and man stoned to death by
monkeys in India they threw rocks at him
they hit him on the head chest and legs
they beat him to death with rocks I'm a
good pitcher
Joe I bet you are look if you had a
weapon I like you you if you got
something you could really [__] crack
it with a baseball bat I like you but
the thing is man if you don't and that
thing bites you you're [__] all right
if you got shorts on good luck son it's
going to rip a giant chunk of your thigh
out well these all rules will have to HH
out there's no rules with shimps bro
there's no rules with I'm saying what am
I allowed to wear if I'm shorts or am I
allowed to wear little armor dressed
like am I allowed to wear hel dress like
a knight I'm to fight a monkey [__] Fair
are you on team person or team
monkey what's fair I want you have to be
crazy to fight a monkey in a fair fight
what no you no you're right so what kind
of weapon can I monkey's going to cheat
there's no fair this is going to be a
dirty fight it's okay if I bring a bat I
want a Gun N no gun I want a that's look
we're proving proving something we're
proving something human beings to figure
this out bang shut the [__]
up you got to get in a [__] arm
wrestling match with the gorilla boom
shut the [__] up we figured that out
okay right so that's fair enough yeah
you don't want to be fighting but for
entertainment value but it just shows
how weak we are in comparison to what we
think even strong people what is this a
six-month-old girl was being breastfed
in her mother's lap in a courtyard room
in her home and a small village in North
India uh a population approximately
5,000 a maau entered the room through an
open door and apparently without
provocation snatched the infant from her
the monkey then proceeded to LEAP From
the Terrace to Terrace Holdings the
infant while being pursued by local
residences dropped it was W the monkey
eventually dropped it that's crazy oh BR
burrow yeah I'm telling you man you
don't want to [__] with a monkey all
right I think
I think it would it would shock you I
had a chimp on news radio once and I
don't even think that that I think that
scene got cut from the final episode
because it was something something had
to do with animals so we had animals and
so we had this Chimp on set and I did
not have a scene with the chimp but I
was there so I got to like hold on to
the chimp and like hang on hang out with
it maybe I did have a scene with it I
don't remember whatever it was this
chimp was a baby in a diaper and it was
so strong dude
it was hitting my back just playing you
know just tapping me and I was like whoa
yeah there was one on SNL and I got to
go in the room baby or him and he kept
saying don't let him don't let him nip
at you don't let him he left me alone
for like 30 seconds and all I remember
is the skull skull is really hard it was
like a it was like a coconut that thing
was very powerful dude they don't yeah
it's a baby but it doesn't feel like you
think a baby should feel like it feels
like a super athlete like when you touch
their muscles even though they're a baby
they're they're so jacked like you feel
their little muscles you're like holy
[__] man you saw the no hair one right
yeah that I mean that is that's what it
is yeah that's just pure yeah and the no
hair one that you see like that one if
you think about the amount of muscle
that thing has it's probably like 180
PBS you got to multiply that times like
four and that's how strong it is in
terms of people right it's it's a
different thing even though it looks so
imp like if it was a dude if it was a
dude that was built but you would fear
it no what I'm saying fear what I'm
saying is you would go that guy's
[__] jacked I bet he's strong well
take what you think about a guy that
looks like that and multiply times four
and that's how strong a chimp is that's
what's scary yeah no that's frightening
all right you convince me I'm not going
to fight the monkey no one can fight a
chimp but a monkey you might have a
chance if you're a bad [__] you
know if you're a good kickboxer like KH
Round Tree he might [__] up a little
monkey you know get him with some leg
kicks yeah I think yeah if the monkey
doesn't understand defense W as long as
you can keep it from biting your face as
long as you can keep it from just
getting a hold of you and biting a chunk
out of
you